a mãe não é de e aí galera que existe no
canal turma você e como está tudo bem
é claro que não sabe por que eu estava
gravando esse vídeo aqui a câmera caiu
no chão é o arquivo do vídeo abre agora
pois ela não estava no meu quarto é como
vocês podem perceber o aterro mar o
quarto arrumado já pode saber que não é
mesmo ainda estamos em fortaleza que
beleza hein o dia 7 às quatro da tarde a
gente vai estar na bilheteria do teatro
via sul 3 você quiser me ver quiser ver
cá e todo mundo achou da área só sei lá
no teatro via sul na bilheteria no dia 7
às quatro da tarde estão a gente bate
papo tá idéia então nesse tempo é que eu
vivo eu tô percebendo que tem muitas
coisas que não entendo agora não entendo
quase tudo só que eu vou dizer aqui
agora algumas coisas que eu entendo não
entendo porque sempre uma pessoa chega
pra mim fala assim é preciso falar com
você você fala beleza então foi a pessoa
fala não agora não posso falar agora não
entendo se você já gastou a sua saliva
para dizer olha eu preciso falar com
você que não falam logo que tinha pra
falar animal ao índice mais o assunto
talvez seria muito grande talvez não é
um assunto que se possa falar em público
então por que não espera para falar só
na hora de falar que a pessoa tem que
avisar que ela vai falar não vou morrer
amanhã vou morrer depois de amanhã vou
morrer de curiosidade você fica falando
assim ele decide falar com você mas não
posso falar agora tomado outra coisa que
não entendo porque assim tem gente que
não gosta de celular tem gente que não
tem celular e da opção e talvez porque o
celular para cada vez mais se tornou
parte do corpo e por exemplo ela é quase
um órgão do meu eu sei meu salário não
funcionam direito ao burro é mais uma
das coisas a massa demais foi aí que vi
em campo me amou demais falar mas acho
que seja pra casa tutela sair pra valer
só para falar aqui
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah eu quero entender
porque há definições de vírus do havas
só atualiza quando a gente está
distraído que notícia é essa
nicole bahls usa o mesmo vestido em duas
festas
meu deus como ela pode ser capaz de uma
coisa death deus não acredito em xeque
as definições de vírus foram atualizadas
é incrível e está quase exemplo eu acho
que eu acho que devia usar esse alerta
do vasco na pessoa sábados em fartas
incida shop
acho que ver se chove usar esse alerta
do avast
as definições de vírus foram a toalha e
provou que não entendo por que contar
muito frio a gente se embrulha aí começa
a ficar quente retira aí fica frio
demais ea gente símbolo e fica nesse
loop infinito pra sempre só que o
negócio é a gente singular de novo só
que a gente deixou a perna do lado de
fora fica fica perfeito cara fica o
equilíbrio da vida meu deus só que
depois a gente percebe que o pé da gente
está vulnerável demais pode ser
racionais ou menino deus está debaixo da
cama impulso para a gente mas é assim
mesmo tem muito com o que tem na vida e
agora quero saber de você eu quero que
você comente aqui em baixo o que você
não entende nessa vida desse vídeo e não
aí ele mandou seu mandato que tem que
dar a 2 mas é público não gostei isso
ajuda demais a gente fazendo isso é a
primeira vez que está assistindo o vídeo
meu canal clique em inscrever se tudo
estiver ouvindo você vai saber primeiro
link primeiro link na descrição do vídeo
da lógica no ic é o que me ajuda com
essas coisas que essa câmera que isso é
muito me deu e tab tem embaixo aquilo
então meu twitter pra você me seguir no
twitter
embaixo do meu facebook embaixo também
está bem eu já disse que é muito
importante que vocês ilha porque às
vezes no youtube não te entrega o vídeo
às vezes no youtube não não enviou o
vídeo para você então se você me seguir
nas redes sociais não é que ele não
visitava lembro de assistir seguida até
aqui e fiquem agora com imagens do sana
aqui em fortaleza que foi muito massa
levei um choque na bunda doeu muito e eu
quero que vocês vêem não esquece o dia 7
às quatro da tarde no teatro via sul na
bilheteria vai ter fotos ao eu fiz quem
quiser ir lá e tá bettencourt vai ser
minha licença e roupa na líbia levou das
colegiais aí
em setembro o índice vai colocar no
youtube
também hoje foi muito participada
populares como ai ai
ae
the right to vida é político é
já falei
todas as vitórias da portuguesa
paul shin devine o fato ao título quem
vai dar é grafado na final
é como diz o outro muito eu faço tudo
isso diz praia grande é competitivo
foi perfeito
e aí não posso viver uma guerra pessoal
essa espera um bom público
aproveitar e fazer bonito no rio
é que ocorre no mundo
além do mais isso
essas duas vezes aí a concluir que só
poderia ficar com o filé julgamento
a água
o papel
ego
gaga
ah
é bom
ae
é
ah